[Musique]
dans certains commerces New Yorkais on
sert ses bouillons d'os comme des cafés
pour emporter
et des mixologues les utilisent même
comme ingrédients clés dans la création
de cocktail les bouillons d’œufs sont
aussi populaires sur les réseaux sociaux
et dans le milieu de l'entraînement où
l'on croit qu'il favorise la perte de
gras et le gain de masse musculaire
grâce à leur forte teneur en protéines
en vitamines et en minéraux
cause de sa concentration en collagène
certaines personnes lui attribuent des
vertus de cure de jouvence
amazing certains des nouveaux produits
ont vraiment pris un axe santé très
fonctionnel où on nous vante les vertus
pratiquement curatives de certains
bouillons que ce soit pour la peau pour
la santé digestive les articulations etc
il y a pas d'études scientifiques
solides qui ont été fait sur les
bouillons d'os pour confirmer la chose
j'ai vu de la poudre de bouillon d'os à
ajouter un smoothie on s'en sert
vraiment comme ingrédient fonctionnel
donc une façon d'enrichir par exemple le
smoothie et en protéines et de lui
donner de la texture parce qu'un bon
bouillon d’œuf qui était bien fait en
tout cas déjà dans les échantillons
qu'on a trouvé avait entre 4 et 9 g de
protéines par tasse alors qu'un bouillon
traditionnel on n'a pas le C0 ou 1 g on
en parle même pas là
contrairement au simple bouillon le
bouillon d’œuf est fabriqué en faisant
mijoter les os la moelle et les tissus
de poulet ou de boeuf à base température
pendant de très très longues heures
si je prends celui-là entre autres
beaucoup plus dispendieux mais dans les
marques qu'on retrouve vraiment dans les
grandes surfaces dont imagine on a une
proposition de bouillon d'os qui est
vraiment très intéressante bien fait peu
d'ingrédients 9 g de protéines par tasse
donc le ça devient pas juste un
ingrédient aromatisant mais ça devient
un aliment en soi qu'on peut consommer
par lui-même
en spécialise ici en découpe de
carcasses entières et on travaille
vraiment tout du museau à la queue
et les eaux à la boucherie petite patrie
ce n'est pas ce qui manque on peut
toujours aller à gauche des
os des ailes
toujours bon et c'est moins cher
les aromates ça c'est à la base oignon
carottes céleri ail avec un bouquet
garni moi je conseille souvent aussi aux
gens de garder leurs chute de légumes
dont les pelures de l'oignon les boules
et carottes les purs de carottes on peut
regarder son congélateur amener à
Bouillon ensuite il va toujours avoir
les impuretés que dans les eaux on peut
écumer faire un bouillon qui va être
plus clair
votre bouillon maison coûte environ 32
cents partage bouillons d’œuf qui est
vieux comme le monde mais il reprend ses
lettres de noblesse ce qui est à faire
sur le marché en ce moment comme
bouillon d'os ce sont des produits qui
semblent plus naturels au niveau de leur
composition que le reste des bouillons
qu'on se trouve à avoir j'ai beaucoup
moins d'ajouts d'ingrédients et
notamment d'exhausteurs de goût un
bouillon d'os qui est bien fait vient
avec beaucoup de saveurs donc on a moins
besoin d'en ajouter dedans la grosse
différence aussi ça va être le taux de
sodium et beaucoup de sens 45% dans
presque tous les types de Bouillon qui
sont sur le marché en ce moment des
options moins salées voire censé
l'ajouter existe et il en existe
plusieurs et on le voit d'ailleurs les
écarts de teneur en sodium si je prends
juste la catégorie des prêts à utiliser
donc ceux qu'on a pas dilué dans nos
échantillons-savarie de 30 mg à 910 mg
par portion de 250 ml donc faut vraiment
regarder les étiquettes parce les écarts
sont majeurs d'un produit à l'autre dans
le déshydraté ça a été long avant qu'on
ait des produits quand même assez
intéressants ou de qualité mais on en a
quelques-uns sur le marché en ce moment
qui sont vraiment bien donc ceux-là de
goubio qui ont des en fait qui sont
censés ajouter donc les ingrédients qui
sont dedans ceux qui sont naturellement
porteurs de sodium en contiennent mais
la teneur finale est faible puis j'ai
particulièrement aimé ce petit produit
là bouillons déshydraté donc long
conservation encore une fois c'est le
seul produit de nos échantillons il sera
entièrement fait au Québec et avec un
profil de composition et de valeur
nutritive qui somme toute pour un
déshydrater vraiment très bien à la
maison je vais faire des bouillons
tandis que ici vraiment la boucherie on
se concentre beaucoup sur les fonds
c'est un petit peu plus versatile pour
si on veut faire des sauces après des
trucs comme ça
pour boire comme ça pour des soupes je
conseille vraiment le bouillon
la différence entre un simple bouillon
et un bouillon d'os la patience
la plus grande différence en fait ça va
être le temps de cuisson qui est
vraiment plus longue en général 12
heures il va faire sortir le collagène
des eaux un bouillon c'est quelque chose
qui est un petit peu plus rapide donc
normalement on peut le faire en trois à
quatre heures
à l'oeil en bouche et en nutriments un
bouillon d'os qui a mijoté plusieurs
heures voire des jours et beaucoup plus
concentré j'ai latineux que le bouillon
du côté de Cambo c'est un de mes
produits coup de coeur sur l'ensemble de
la gamme la composition qui est vraiment
bien pour un produit transformé de ce
type là teneur en sodium raisonnable et
beaucoup moins d'emballage et de risque
de gaspillage donc belle innovation du
côté de Cambo dans les concentrés c'est
franchement les plus intéressants
curiosité ici pour moi better and
bouillon une base aux légumes donc il
peut être une option assez intéressante
aussi si on veut des très petites
portions et une texture assez
surprenante absolument au chapitre des
innovations dans cette catégorie là
c'est un truc qui sort vraiment du lot
c'est un produit américain on voit qu'on
est vraiment dans une pâte épaisse faut
prendre ça vraiment comme un concentré
donc ouvrez ou autre traditionnel qu'on
connaît dans les concentrés on ne veut
pas cuisiner avec quelque chose de trop
liquide parce qu'on veut donner de la
consistance à notre main à notre sauce
c'est quoi les usages principaux du
bouillon
je remplace souvent l'eau par le
bouillon on va chercher un bouillon de
poulet ou de bœuf déjà prêt uniquement
pour les arômes et la saveur mais
absolument pas pour se nourrir il y a
rien de nourrissant là-dedans c'est
vraiment un ingrédient aromatique ou
aromatisant qui se prêtent à plusieurs
choses sans vouloir faire de mauvais jeu